[music playing]
NARRATOR: Sure,
most would say World
War I started with a gunshot.
[gunshot]
But there's a lot
more to the story.
This is Leopold Lojka.
He was born on
September 17, 1886,
in the old Bohemian
village of Teltsch.
Originally a horse
wrangler, Leopold
moved on to real horsepower
when he became Archduke Franz
Ferdinand's chauffeur in 1909.
Archduke Ferdinand
was first in line
to the Austro-Hungarian
throne, then
occupied by emperor
Franz Joseph I.
But serving as emperor wasn't
all it was cracked up to be.
Austria-Hungary wasn't
exactly the most popular
European country at the time.
1908, the Austro-Hungarian
empire annexes Bosnia.
This ticks off
Bosnian nationalists
who wanted to unify all
southern Slavic countries
under one government.
[cheering]
Tensions are still high in
1914, when Archduke Ferdinand
decides to visit Bosnia.
If there were any place where
Ferdinand were to get got,
Sarajevo, Bosnia's
capital, would be it.
Despite this, Ferdinand
decides to drive
around Sarajevo with the
top down in his limousine.
Leopold Lojka is driving when,
out of the corner of his eye,
he spots a small bomb
hurtling towards the Archduke
and his wife.
He slams on the gas.
And the bomb misses its target.
[engine rumbling]
[bomb explodes]
[music playing]
The bomb was thrown by
Nedeljko Cabrinovic,
a member of the young
Serbian nationalist movement.
There are a few injuries.
But Ferdinand and his
wife are unharmed.
After gathering their
bearings, Leopold drives
on to a scheduled meet and
greet between the Archduke
and local officials.
The officials want to take the
Archduke on a tour of the city.
But Ferdinand, instead, decides
he wants to visit the wounded
victims from the bomb attack.
He gets back into
the car with his wife
and has Leopold drive
off to the hospital.
In all fairness to Leopold, he
didn't know the exact route,
no map, no GPS.
He made a mistake and turned
onto the wrong street.
Unfortunately for Leopold,
and the rest of Europe,
this was the street where
Gavrilo Princip, one
of the co-conspirators of the
earlier assassination attempt,
happened to be having a drink.
Princip can't believe his luck.
He has an opportunity
to finish out what
he started earlier that day.
[tires screeching]
[brakes whine]
[man gasps]
[gunshots]
[crowd screaming]
[music playing]
As the crowd tries
to subdue Princip,
the Archduke and his wife
are left bleeding in the car.
One bullet struck the Archduke
in the neck, the other,
his wife in the stomach.
Both die within the hour.
[music playing]
In response to the assassination
of the heir to its crown,
Austria-Hungary seeks
support from Germany.
Germany agrees.
And Austria Hungary
declares war on Serbia.
Russia, Serbia's ally,
mobilizes its forces.
And as a result, Germany
declares war on Russia.
Russia's ally,
France, then mobilizes
its forces, which causes Germany
to declare war on France.
In turn, Great Britain
declares war on Germany.
Austria-Hungary, then
declares war on Russia.
Serbia declares war on Germany.
And France and Great Britain
declare war on Austria-Hungary.
[music playing]
The first World War
has begun and all
because of a wrong turn.